[Music]
hello I'm Sarah Jamie and welcome to in
this together the podcast that brings
you the good news stories for the week
because we could do it a bit of that
right now
we'll bring you inspirational tales from
around the globe the lighter moments and
the local heroes who are doing fantastic
things to help others in the face of
coronavirus coming up love islands dr.
Alex brings us positive news from the
frontline of covert 19 checking in
mental health campaigners Bryan Gordon
and Matt Johnson remind us is okay not
to be okay during a global pandemic as
Facebook's favourite Chris Kamara on how
subtle is moving online for charity and
what he thinks should happen to the game
in real life our first guest came to the
nation's attention as he went looking
for love on TVs love island now he is
capturing the hearts of the nation as
one of our NHS heroes on the frontline
of covert 19 he's just about to head off
to start shift in A&E at Lewisham
Hospital in London it is dr. Alex George
dr. Alex hello hello hello how are you
doing yeah I'm very well thank you how
are you how are you doing you're going
into hospital every day to treat people
with kovat 19 just give us an idea of
what it's like at the moment it's been
quite thrilled to be honest I mean I was
saying this to one of my friends last
night I was speaking to them it is all
very surreal it's weird I never thought
my career that anything like this would
happen I spoken to consultant supalen
Department for nearly 30 years and they
said that you know they've never seen
anything like this and it's been quite
stressful that's been hard at times and
it's very unusual to have a situation
where you you the country's in lockdown
you're going in to work and things are
all very different but the fact that
everyone's work all together has been so
important I thinking and getting through
this Alex one thing that struck me is
obviously not just you and your NHS
colleagues stepping up in terms of
treating people for kovat 19 but you're
stepping up in terms of reminding people
that you're all human beings there's a
great picture you put on social media of
you and all your PPE gear which can be
really in
timid ating to those who are met with
their doctors wearing it and you've got
a picture of you and when you are in
love island just saying who you are big
smiley face and that's so important
isn't it remembering that these people
are coming to you they're ill they're
frightened and now they're alone because
they can't have their loved ones with
them it's so different it goes against
some of Olivar and you know the ways
that we practice normally and the kind
of our beliefs about how to care for
patients and how to support them for
difficult times do wearing a pee-pee you
look very intimidating scary if you
imagine a little old lady coming into
the you know hospitals and well they've
got there's seven or eight people
running around and in all this gear it's
really intimidating it's not it's not
the way that we want to obviously be we
want to kind of comfort patients and
that the picture' idea was a the end of
a shifter just to kind of lighten the
mood and make people smile for a moment
I think maybe you'll realise as well
that underneath we're still same old
people and I use the most dark picture I
could find a better effect you know at
work it has been a huge thing to support
each other as well as we've seen some
things that are incredibly difficult
some of the things I've seen I'll never
forget in my lifetime I've seen people
come in and I'm so you're very very well
even young people that you know lost
their lives and I won't forget that and
I'm lucky to have had you know moments
of other members of staff who've been so
kind and supportive to each other we
getting support from your colleagues but
you're getting huge support from the
public as well Alex
I mean the stay home keep safe protect
the NHS campaign people are really
taking that to their heart and on the
front line can you see that working can
you see the public working for you
yeah definitely it's been I think the
public reaction the whole is incredible
like you know the vast majority of
people have stayed at home and and done
what we've asked them to do really and
that is so so important and actually
that has resulted in the decreased
figures if we hadn't have been locked
out if people didn't follow social
distancing we would see a probably a
similar figure and rise of cases as
they're seeing in the US which you know
they're having huge issues all around it
seems but yeah we're very very fortunate
the public supported that and also that
there's support every like Thursday with
a crap the little things the the kind of
messages of support as well we know down
in chess the act
do make a difference sometimes all you
need is a little bit of come on we've
got this we believe in you it does
really lift your spirits and you know
kind of make you feel even more
determined it's it's really incredible
it's been it's been great to see how I
love alex is even when you're not on
shift and you're around with a Thursday
night for clap for carries you're out
there with your pots and pans as well
yeah absolutely I mean he's my first
well actually my second time I'd be not
on shift when when it was on yeah
absolutely I've got you know I just want
to be part of the support you know
others that are working at that time as
well and people are working around the
clock 24/7 to kind of battle this crisis
and it was it was really amazing I was
outside just on my doorstep clapping and
I was shaking my wooden spoon around and
people are people are out there cheering
shouting it's incredible to see you
mentioned there about the situation in
the United States obviously we're
watching this unfold all over the world
and how hospitals are coping and I saw
it and a lovely couple of pictures on
social media actually of a hospital in
Brooklyn here you are taking the
positives out of this situation and
celebrating the survivors for everybody
they treat who recovers from covert 19
and get sent home they're putting a
daffodil in the window of the hospital
and it really reminds you that there are
positives in this situation there are
people surviving covered 19 attics yes
absolutely I think it's very easy I
guess to focus on the figures that I'm a
desk pertain it is obviously death is a
huge loss it's sad to see that you know
anyone lose their lives but we are
winning a lot of time as well there's a
lot of patients that I see that come
into the department that we give some
treatments to do it getting them home
you know we've had that low ladies in
the ward who's been in for five days and
they've gone home so it's not always you
know the bad news or the bad news you
know story and it is important to kind
of celebrate those successes I think in
and in seeing people go home it's really
again it lifts you your your mood your
spirits because you think yes we're
doing this for a reason we can and save
and support people I think a lot of
people think they capture b19 there's
nothing we can do but of course yes we
can't treat the virus directly we allow
the body to kind of develop community
and
like the Baris what we do is everything
we possibly can support the body until
the virus has kind of been beaten by the
immune system you are taking the
positives and from your work Alex and
the public are really treating you at
the moment and it's interesting it's not
just the clap for carers it's raising
money for NHS charities it's practical
support as well because I understand
that you and have a sticky situation
accommodation wise and somebody stepped
in and then you've also got people
sending things like meals and treats and
gift bags to the hospital I mean people
really want to help you and look after
you yeah work we've you know we've seen
people sending in food parcels for
companies and you know large companies
sending you know meals into and small
restaurant chains to individuals kind of
cooking meals or sending in treats and
Alex how are you looking after your own
health and I'm not just talking about
the physical I'm talking about your
mental health as well because as you
said you had to move flats and it's not
like he could move into a flat chair
because working on the front line you
have to be isolated when you're not at
work in terms of coming to into contact
with too many people and obviously that
means you can't see your loved ones at
the moment so how are you looking after
yourself I've been making sure exercise
each day I mean I've been eating a lot
of these treat sentence about to do
quite a lot of cycling is kind of kind
of a little bit a lot a lot of cycling
each day and which is great do you mind
as well as we're allowed to have this in
a pure time out to exercise each day and
I think utilizing that is really really
important for me being out on the open
road going through psychologically as my
head and I also make sure I face my
family I really make sure that I'm
engaging and talking communicating with
people around me looking after my mental
health but things like meditating as
well I found that really helpful there's
a lot of thoughts that run in your mind
I've got a busy shift you come home and
you've seen all these things your mind
in a lot of ways are still on shift you
know you're still in your mind running
around and it's hard to kind of unwind
some time so I do actually meditate and
to try and help slow things down and
clear your mind because otherwise you
come home into an empty house and you're
still buzzing in your map in your mind
and you're still really really
overactive you know there's a lot of
talk about the lock down at the moment
people are pressuring the government to
come up with a plan as to how
to get out of it you've seen the effect
of what's going on what would your
message to those people be who are
thinking of leaving lockdown simply
because they're bored of staying at home
I think what we could say is that we
know now from looking back on a date
that we've done has were locked out of
house it has been successful was
prevented potentially you know a huge
number of more deaths than we've already
had if we all go right it's kind of work
let's abandon ship and don't do it in
that controlled manner then we're gonna
see a spike again I think that's really
very very likely whereas if we kind of
take this day by day you know we create
measures that are kind of sensible I'm
sure the government will we'll be
outlining under coming in a days and
weeks that way we can kind of monitor
the levels and not have this horrible
spike because ultimately we don't want
to happen is over a week or so have
massive number of cases overwhelming
down a chest that is the problem because
up to Lau because what we've done we've
been able to cope yes you know it's
become very very busy we've been able to
cope I don't want to go into hospital
and see that we don't have enough beds
to treat people you'll find out we don't
have enough ventilators because the
cases have shot up so everyone's our the
fantastic job and thank you to everyone
that's been you know really it's not
easy to be in lockdown it's not easy you
know I know the idea of stay at home
it's not that easy and I get that
mentally but it has made a difference
and we're nearly there so keep going
yeah stay patient stay home save lives
protect the NHS dr. alex i know you've
got to go on shift now a lucien hospital
thank you for speaking to us and from
everyone listening actually just thank
you for the work you're doing every day
to you and your colleagues thank you so
much thank you I've been talking today
it's great to share some of my stuff
thank you
my next guest on mental health
campaigners that are taking to Instagram
to support and offer advice and let's
face it a good old-fashioned laughs as
well to get us through these strange and
difficult times they are briny golden
journalists and co-founder of mental
health mates and broadcaster and mind
charity ambassador Matt Johnson hello hi
hi there well it's good to chat to you
just wanted to check in really and find
out how both of you are doing because
obviously you're taking care of other
people on Instagram
to check in and make sure everyone's
alright and keep everyone talking now
how are you doing I was thinking about
this I I don't know and I've spoken to
Matt a lot about this but I feel like I
was quite well prepped for this sort of
disaster like my head it's about nine
years old someone who's experienced
depression and obsessive-compulsive
disorder and addiction and all I sound
like I'm going on and on but I feel like
I've been I've been prepping for the
apocalypse since I was about nine like
the worst thing I've been thinking of
the worst things that could happen but I
do think I do think that the thing is I
think also at the beginning of lockdown
I thought as someone who's experienced
as mental health issues that I'd quite
like the fact I don't have to go out and
see people anymore I don't have to go to
all those meetings that I used to fight
anxiety inducing and actually I realize
how much those little areas of normal
life keep you saying the things that you
don't want to do are weirdly the things
that keep you going right yeah it's
interesting isn't it Matt because for a
lot of people I know a lot of people who
can be quite reclusive or saying they're
actually enjoying this time and they
feel guilty about saying that but then
other people I know you have mental
health issues very different types of
saying you know when you're alone that's
when it can resurface so they really
have to you know make sure that they
have a routine and they check in with
people on a regular basis yeah that's
very very true one of my things before
this lockdown was that I quite like
being locked down myself and I've been
through a lot of time as you know when
you're freelance you have a long long
time sometimes to yourself when you
realize that you do need routine you do
need to exercise and and I so I've had
some experience and as far as what what
myself and Briony and everybody are
trying to do is to try and reach people
to to help people understand that it
doesn't necessarily matter what your
routine was before we have to be present
and in the moment and deal with our
situation right now and the biggest
response that have had from people is is
that they are lacking passion lacking
enthusiasm to do anything and I think a
lot of people are really blaming
themselves or given themselves a hard
time because they're not making 10
loaves of banana bread a day and because
they're not raising millions of
in their gardens and the biggest message
that we want to kind of push out is that
it's okay to have an off day and it's
okay to have a bad day and it's fine
also if you want to raise lots of money
in your garden the general consensus for
me is that these are as everybody says
unprecedented times but we have to have
some sort of schedge or some sort of
routine
look after yourself but also looking
after yourself it's also going easy on
yourself because I know from personal
experience when you're sitting around
any house in your own you can drive
yourselves literally mad with things
that you think you should do yeah Briony
that's interesting I saw on your
Instagram page a post that literally
said it's okay not to be most productive
during a global pandemic because that's
what can be overwhelming online is all
these pictures and videos of people
keeping busy learning achieving creating
yeah I think I I mean I think that you
suddenly had at the beginning of it you
had this sort of Russian of people doing
home workouts and people saying that
they were gonna do this crafting with
their children and this schedule of
their home schooling and this is a
really abnormal situation and it's
really normal to respond to it in an
uncomfortable way and I've heard a lot
of people say to me oh I feel like I
should be in a routine now you know were
five six weeks in and why haven't I work
this out and I'm like guys this is huge
like let's just stop for a moment the
world has not ended right but the world
as we know it has okay and these are
huge things to have to process so yes if
you're not doing loads of choreographed
dance routines on tik-tok if you haven't
taught your child the contents of the
entire you know encyclopedia sounds very
old-school doesn't it you haven't
managed to be doing hit classes every
morning or even managing to get to PE
with Joe Wix you know that's okay you've
got to do what's best for you and we
will look back on this time I'm sure and
go wow that was weird
but when you're talking to viewers on
Instagram live when you and Brian II do
your sessions what are the things that
people are bringing up the most and what
kind of tips and advice have been shared
because
often it's by talking to strangers that
you uncover things that you might not
necessarily have thought of before that
change your way of thinking so I know
that you share a lot of information with
your Instagram user so it's just
wondering what you'd found most useful
or it surprised you the most important
thing I think a lot of people are
starting to realize and I am starting to
realize along the way is that it is it's
genuinely to go easy on yourself and
just take one day at a time and to take
all that weight of expectation that you
might look on social media and see
somebody doing something incredible and
that might make you feel bad so I think
a lot of people have been telling me
that they are they are choosing their
information wisely so they they're not
watching rolling news all the time
because that can be in these
circumstances quite upsetting and can it
can heighten anxiety so they're picking
a time to choose to watch the news and
to get the information and where to get
the information wisely and they're
really budgeting their amount of social
media use so I think a lot of people are
accessing and using quite rightly
Instagram live from about 5 p.m. through
to about 10 p.m. the evening I think a
lot of people are starting to realize
that you have to be okay in your own
skin and too much information sometimes
especially especially doing this
pandemic can be a bad thing to your
mental health
social media enabled me to set up mental
health mates which is this peer support
group social media has enabled me to see
you know images of women who look
different to the ones I see mostly on
mainstream media you know social media
has made me feel more normal and I think
you've got to sound it sounds awful but
curate it when I do those map those
lives with math like when I'm just doing
this now with you to see other people in
other rooms doing I feel quite emotional
I'm not having a great time of it and
that's fine you know and to be able to
be really honest about that with other
people for me and my career has been the
most powerful tool of healing sounds it
sounds so cheesy but I have to be honest
about it and so that importance of
connects
and I've always said this all mental
health issues what they have in common
be from anxiety anxiety through to
psychosis and beyond is that they lie to
you and they tell you you're a freak and
they tell you that you're alone and they
tell you that no one's gonna understand
what you're going through
they isolate you okay so the the way
through that is to connect with others
we here in recovery circles so often
that a dick the opposite of addiction is
connection and so it's really important
for us to be you know using these modes
of social media in a way that supports
our mental health rather than perhaps
drains it what I really like is being
able to touch and hug and feel other
people and connect them and see the
tears in their eyes and put my arms
around them and tell them it's gonna be
okay and even if it's not okay it'll
it's always okay in the end
and that's what you know we need and
this is the closest thing to it Matt and
I on our lives have like we come up with
two bits of good news we've heard each
day and I do think an attitude of
gratitude does really help right at the
beginning the first thing that everybody
jumped towards or everybody wanted to do
was connect with people so you had these
apps that are all set to help me zoom
apps and everything else everybody and
their dog was facetiming their family
straightaway which I thought was an
incredible thing like subconsciously
everybody went oh I can't see my nan I'm
gonna Sleater every day and and you
might have seen your nan for a couple of
months beforehand but the first thing
that everybody jumped to when you got
when he was taken away from then then
was human interaction and a connection
which is something that working in the
mental health world is huge there's a
huge lack of connection in this modern
era
we're very connected via our mobile
phones and social media but we're not
actually that sociable we don't actually
communicate to people's faces and I
think that could be a reason why a lot
of people suffering from mental illness
have never been on so many house parties
in my entire life and I have to say
after week three it was pretty boring
and now they're really important because
you feel really amazing afterwards and
I'm going through that phase now after
week six where I'm like
bit tired checking in with lots of
people all the time and I want to be on
my own I want to watch some box sets
again but when I do have a conversation
like this and when I check in with mates
with it Pub Quiz or whatever we do is
that great feeling of connection and
that's what I think is one of the things
we're going to take from all of this is
how people subconsciously or consciously
clambered to other people which
hopefully will be one positive thing to
take from this yeah and that brings me
to my final question do you think
attitudes towards mental health and the
resources and the attitudes that the go
towards helping those who suffer with
their mental health will change after
this because everybody as she said
everybody in some way because of what
we're going through is being directly
affected I hope that we are you know now
it's the government invest as they
should have been doing for years in the
NHS but not just in the areas that have
been you know not just in the kind of
terms at the PPE and the ventilators and
all the things we're here talking about
but also in the mental health services
have been slashed and cut back to their
bare bones because there are going to be
people that need them now more than ever
but people grieving but people you know
nurses doctors as well who have seen
traumatic things and and let this be a
moment let this be a wake-up call to how
important it is to nurture all of our
health care be it physical or mental let
there be no more slashing the budgets
done hopefully something positive that
will come out of this will be attitudes
towards and mental health briney and
that you're doing your bit on social
media to keep people connected and
supported thank you so much for talking
to us on in this together stay safe and
stay sane as well
now a big sporting event disappeared
from our Diaries this week because of
the lockdown the London Marathon has
been postponed and with it much needed
funds last year the event raised over 66
million for over a thousand different
charities but yet again the public have
found a way and the 2.6 challenge was
created the idea behind it the
challenges come up with an activity
based around the numbers 2.6 or 26 the
marathon of course is 26.2 miles long
they then get sponsorship to raise funds
thousands of people up and down the
country have been taking part this week
for their chosen charity doing all sorts
of things not just the traditional
running or cycling there's nine year old
Melissa Newland she raised more than
five hundred pounds by sitting in a bath
tub of cornflakes for 2.6 hours to
support her mum who works as a nurse at
Lindsay Lodge Hospice in Scunthorpe
we've had hula hooping for Parkinson's
and we've even had someone eating
chillies for MS Society for my next
guest is something a bit different as
well but then you can always rely on him
to bring the fun to any situation
he is Sky Sports finest and Ninja
Warrior host Chris Kamara kami I'm very
good thank you
lovely see you're cheerful smiley face
and here
smiley voice I mean of course you would
do something fun for the two-point-six
challenge tell everybody where you got
up to for Mary Curie it's only because
my back is out of business I haven't
seen my chiropractor now for six weeks
so I am in absolute agony so I was gonna
run around and do some stuff but I
thought there's no way in this world
that I can possibly do that so what I
did is I took my granddaughter out Billy
who is not very old she is nine and a
half weeks old to rise I walk along take
up walks virtually every afternoon so I
thought it'd be a good idea some days
she stays awake the whole time well the
day she goes to sleep
very very early so depending on her mood
so I thought well I'll do the challenge
could
do it in two point six minutes which
would be a record 26 minutes or two
hours and six minutes anyway
thankfully the ground that I was walking
along was really really bumpy so two
point six minutes it was a record Finney
was coined to Billie was kind to
granddad and very cute shoes -
congratulations Cammy and
you're keeping busy tell me about this
NHS Charities together cup that you're
putting on well it's all those people
are into FIFA gaming and all that type
of stuff yes a Ben Stokes and Stuart
Broad they were part of it and quite a
few other players as well dilly and
white the boxer so what they're doing is
they're playing Fifa 20 and we're having
sort like a qualified on semifinals and
a final next Sunday which hopefully will
bring in bundles of bundles of money for
the NHS charities together
Kop it's called and all charities
benefit from this game depending how
much money they raise yeah it's an
all-star cast you've mentioned some of
the names there it's not just football
is getting involved but cricketers I
understand you've got a wrestler in
there as well and how did the public get
involved how do they watch because it's
gonna be interesting isn't it because
everybody regardless of what sport
they're into what sport they play
professionally always think they're
really good at FIFA yeah they do and Ben
Stokes was so lucky yesterday because
Chris board
carried him through I have to say so he
you know he's a worldly at cricket but
he's not such a world at feet 420 I have
to say people come watch it stream it on
YouTube and all places like that and I
didn't know existed until they got me
involved in this I love that your son's
been helping you set up for a zoom call
today it's good to have techy people in
the family isn't it when we're all
broadcasting from home or trying to keep
in touch with loved ones and friends I
wouldn't have been able to do anything
so honestly I swear to god my son
and his wife and their two kids Solomon
and Billy they live in a flat in Leeds
so six weeks ago before the lockdown
he'd heard from a friend in Japan about
what was actually going on and he said
look you're gonna get locked down in the
flat so they they decided to move in
with us which was great my other son
with his partner and their daughter
Connie they live next door so we're so
fortunate so lucky
we're self isolating together so if
there is any massive plus from all of
this we are the best family time you
could ever ever imagine it's it's been
incredible yeah it's a real blessing
cami but you're coming together as a
family to do good work as well because
that's what a lot of people are doing
when they're sitting at home thinking
how can I make a difference obviously
there's the NHS charities together cup
that you're doing and you've been
raising money for Mary Curie with your
two-point-six challenge and these
charities away from the NHS charities
really do need people's help at the
moment more than ever right now because
so many of the big fundraisers have been
cancelled or postponed things like the
London Marathon and obviously you can't
go out and fundraise in the same way
that you used to so charities like Mary
Curie I'm really missing out right now
and need people to help them Oh without
a doubt in March
Mary Curie raises almost 6 million
pounds every single year which allows
the hospices people go on into people's
homes to care for the elderly
anybody who's terminally ill all those
types of things is what Mary Curie do
but because of the coronavirus March was
a complete dead rubber I think something
like four hundred thousand pounds was
raised in that month so we've had to
think of ways how on earth we can get
people to donate because well I have to
say it the UK is the most generous
people in the world we give more to
charity than any other country
around and people's generosity amazes
you so much from time to time so people
are willing to give but they want a
little bit back for something to give I
was in the Navy Sarah Jane before I
became a footballer my dad made me join
the Navy when you sign on the dotted
line for the Navy
you think at one stage it only goes
through your mind very briefly I might
have to go to war for my country and
there's a possibility by going to war I
might not come home as a nurse or a
doctor or a care worker you are there to
look after people how on earth you could
possibly in in our lifetime be doing
your job and the possibility have you
not coming home to your family
at some stage it's just incredible yeah
kami I agree with all of that and you
know the charity Marie Curie is lucky to
have you fronting you know their
fundraising efforts trying to do new
things trying to keep the interest there
because obviously their work doesn't
stop because of Kovac 19 it continues so
they need our support and cami it seems
weird to ask you this given everything
that's going on but are you missing
football right now obviously because
we're so used to see you every weekend
talking about the Premier League and the
Football League yeah without a doubt I'm
missing football I'm scratching around
for football matches
you know I'm looking on all the channels
going through it you say oh match of the
days all games with the X pros some of
the current games that we've just
watched over the last months or so
they've been revisited on various
channels so yeah of course I'm missing
it of course I'm missing it so let's
take away the element of Kobe 19 and
what's actually happening please as soon
as possible let's revisit the Premier
League I want to do that I think most of
the club's want to do that I don't think
what they want to be like Holland and
actually you know cancel the league
full-time I think everybody wants to
play out as best as we possibly can of
course when you hear somebody like Karen
brady talking about we've got to end it
almost immediately it's human nature
she's at West Ham there bottom of the
table there's a possibility that they
could be relegated she it's human nature
she shouldn't have come out and said it
she should have just thought about it
but that's how the clubs at the bottom
of these leagues will be thinking we
don't mind if it falls but at the end of
the day these decisions that are about
to be made the authorities they've got
to get the majority vote from all these
clubs and all the people involved and
hopefully they'll come up with the right
decision would you guys see being played
behind closed doors just so there is an
ending not a void well I don't mind
actually because of the fact and this is
you know personal we would still be
going to those matches behind closed
doors because obviously we've got to
report them for other people so if
that's the only thing that can happen
then yes but I do believe that the funds
make the Premier League the fans make
the Football League and the fans make
the NAM League so the Premier League is
as big as it is because of the
atmosphere the environment the way that
the fans flock to the stadium and give
it a real turnout and just finally Chris
footballers came in for a bit of stick
at the start of all of this debate over
their wages and so on do you think that
was unfair because there's plenty of
evidence out there at the moment to say
that footballers and the football family
as a whole have been doing their bit
during this crisis whether it's Jordan
Henderson setting up a Premier Li fund
josée Mourinho out delivering food to
the elderly for Age UK I think it was a
bit outrageous full stop really I knew
the footballers would get together to
make a contribution but when you think
of the amount attacks that these
footballers pay I know everybody talks
about how much ridiculous money that
they earn but the amount of taxes they
pay towards the government that goes
towards the NHS they are doing their
little bit in their own little way why
are we singling out footballers that
that is the only thing
pede everybody around you know there are
so many other sports where people are
astronomical amounts of money not just
football
so the lis football around football
we'll saw its own house out Jordan
Henderson got all most of the Premier
League players and it is personal choice
it has to be you know whatever charity
you decide to give to it has to be
personal choice if you decide you're not
gonna give to charity then why should
you be coming for a hammering because of
that you shouldn't it should be your
choice your decision to do it it's all
about it's a free world Sarah let's not
get a blame world everybody doing their
bit as and when they can kami it's been
really good to chat to you thank you so
much for talking to us and stay safe and
we hope to see you out about a football
ground very soon back where you belong
so great to talk to you as well great to
see I haven't seen your face it's the
beauty of all these zoom calls and all
these video chats Gabby we're seeing
more of people that we would have done
ordinarily so that's one of the
positives
take care kami love to the family who
see us in this together at sky don't you
Kate's the email address or you can get
in touch with social media at skyress
Sarah Jane hashtag in this together
[Music]
you